let's turn to the other breaking news
this is a big story the hostage
breakthrough in Israel the Jewish State
and Hamas agreeing to a 4-day pause in
the fighting in a deal that would free
at least 50 women and children held
captive by the Hamas terrorists the deal
was negotiated by cutter with help from
the US and Egypt Israel's prime minister
says he's happy to get the hostages out
but says it will not stop Israel from
destroying
Hamas the war is continuing we continue
to continue the war and till we obtain
all reach all our goals bring all our
objectives back destroy Hamas and assure
it have assurance that no
terrorist no
Terror body will be in charge of Gaga
Gaza will no longer be a threat for
Israel we are winning and we will
continue fighting until the absolute
complete
Victory and we're doing this thanks to
The Bravery of our Fighters
and our and our sons and daughters the
heroes of Israel and their
sacrifices a lot of different angles to
this Joey let me start with you so Hamas
is saying it will say it is because we
are so strong and Israel so weak that we
brought Israel to this point Israel's
point of view is that it's their
military actions that have brought Hamas
to this point and regardless also Israel
says don't think that we are going to do
a permanent ceasefire their goal to
destroy Hamas ultimately is still going
to happen in according to what they're
saying yeah I mean I guess this is why
they have hostages to begin with I mean
they they knew that they were outgunned
and they were probably outmanned and
they were in in Gaza alone they were
going to be under siege in some way um I
think that what I what strikes me about
this is that on October 7th Americans
were murdered we have Americans held
hostage there have been 66 attacks on
Direct attacks on Americans in the
Middle East and I believe 62 Americans
injured we have Americans stationed in
the
Mediterranean we're at War whether we
want to say that or not we are in this
war and I'm not advocating for us to
take any steps of War but the reality is
this is not just Israel and Hamas
fighting a war America is a big player a
big actor in this so when Joe Biden
Praises this and we hear that Qatar and
the US helped negotiated that tells me
Joe Biden wanted this and and probably
put pressure because when you watch
Netanyahu some of the concession that
not to get into the weeds before anybody
else has a chance but they're going to
stop aerial surveillance in South Gaza
for 4 days stop aerial surveillance in
Northern Gaza Strip uh for pretty much
an entire chunk of the day all of
daylight for four days they're giving up
150 prisoners in in the prisoners have
done things so much that Israel says hey
if you're a victim of what these
prisoners have done you have a certain
amount of hours don't if it's 24 or 48
to appeal letting them go so the point
here is Benjamin nyaho doesn't want to
have to do this to get hostage back
because this really is a huge strategic
Advantage for Hamas that is on the
defensive judge one of the things that
you and I are both reading about today
I'm sure you all have too but it's it
was something that struck us as is the
guidance that was given to the IDF the
Israeli Defense Forces for what they are
supposed to say and do when they come
into contact with the children in
particular of the hostages that are
going to be released yeah and it it was
very it very touching and it it's very
compelling I mean the guidance is very
clear the IDF will be the first to get
in touch or to to to reach the children
who are going to be transferred and let
me just say one thing these children
have been in captivity they've been
hostages for seven weeks uh the children
who are being released on the other side
uh by Israel are children who were born
of mothers who've been convicted of
crimes so they are raised in a jail with
their mothers okay so they're with
someone they're familiar with
these children that are going to be
released today are are coming out of
hell and so the guidance is that you
don't touch them you ask them if they if
they want something to drink you ask
them if you can hold their hand if it
looks like it's difficult for them to
walk uh there is no question these kids
are going to have
PTSD uh they're going to they've got to
be checked for health issues as well as
mental health issues going forward uh
they're like the Crime Victims that I
dealt with for so many years they're
vulnerable uh that they they don't feel
that they are you know safe anywhere and
they've got a lot of work to do it um um
to get over that but you know the these
are days of high anxiety and my heart
goes out to those families in Israel
because we've got 50 for 150 of the uh
Hamas convicted women uh and if your
family isn't coming home if your wife or
your daughter or your grandchild isn't
one of them uh what amasa said is well
maybe you can give us a few more days if
we offer you know to let some other
hostages go so they're trying to
elongate the whole thing but it's clear
that that Netanyahu is going to go
forward with destroying Hamas this is a
temporary LOL he didn't even call it a
ceasefire right but Greg you can imagine
that the people who have been calling
for a ceasefire as soon as this pause
happens that they're going to press
really hard and say we could just have
an immediate ceasefire altogether stop
all the fighting their opinion shouldn't
matter we have a we have a protest
movement in the west that is trying to
infect this with identity politics that
somehow if a country gets attacked by
somebody from a different group you
can't fight back imagine if you were
being mugged by a smaller person you
couldn't fight back because that would
be bullying so the fact that like in in
your in the Israeli conflict and in your
own personal safety uh in this realm of
self-defense there should be no identity
politics that's why none of this protest
movement means anything to me because
it's all based in historical context
rather than what's happening since
October 7th but this area what this
breakthrough and I I I hesitate to say
anything about it cuz I I don't have
skin in the game I don't have relatives
that are hostage and if this is good
it's it's it's good for Hamas because
they get time to regroup and they're
torturing these families of hostages as
they wrestle with this uncertainty of
whether it's going to be their kids or
their mother or whatever but if you say
it's bad uh I can't say that to families
may get their children back that's not
for me to say so it's like a it's a it's
a it's a challenge um to figure out what
this is because these are two different
entities you know Israel is fighting to
save lives Hamas doesn't care about
saving lives you know they're happily
put Palestinians in front of uh of guns
and become human targets their goal is
to create the biggest death toll so I
almost feel like like Joey said that
this whole hostage taking thing is built
into the the equation they knew this was
going to happen but it does it raises
questions I mean if you're how do you
negotiate with
Monsters uh who are you negotiating with
and why are they still alive you know if
you can track hostage movements and I
guess you know where they're going to be
held why did they why did they get three
times as many prisoners if it's about
Israel's response you know who who's
holding the cards here I guess is what
I'm getting at and who are we helping by
applying pressure are we helping Israel
by convincing them to do things that
Netanyahu doesn't want to do I don't
know I do think there was a lot of
pressure put on but you're right there's
it's just it's extremely complex and
complicated and Harold it's excruciating
emotional blackmail and one of the
things that's about to happen is family
separation I thought the left didn't
want family separation right I mean we
shouldn't want that but what's going to
happen is you have children who are
going to release perhaps with their
mothers right but their fathers or their
brothers or grandfathers or cousins or
going to be left behind with Hamas so
it's just an excruciating situation so
as we we are naive of Thanksgiving I'm
thankful for a lot of things this is one
of them this is a messy situation this
is this is what war is I think Joey is
right when you say that we are more
engaged than boiled because we have two
unbelievable PR pieces of presence there
some of the best real estate and and
best people that the US military has um
it is clear that we are more involved to
I differ with you guys slightly I think
for those who who are in support of
Palestinians and believe in uh being
activists for better Palestinian life
this should show that everything that
many of us on this panel have been
saying and others have been saying that
this has really been in the hands of
Hamas all along if they had release the
hostages if some who are so active and
so loud and sometimes can be violent in
their activism on behalf of of pal of
Hamas and the Palestinians if Hamas had
released the hostages um it would have
been a lot easier for for the US and
others around the globe to urge
Netanyahu not to wage in Israel not to
respond as forcefully as they had two
netanyahu's made it very clear he's not
stopping now there's PR pressure that is
mounted over the last several weeks he
has not bowed to it he is thankful that
50 Israelis are coming home but he's
made clear we want all of the hostages
so I don't I don't have any doubt that
even though there will be pressure as
Greg you and Dana I think rightly point
out um the that then yaho has made clear
that that is not the direction he's
going finally uh even combatants when
driven when pressured uh be it military
pressure or other towards a Humane goal
even combatants can find their way
somehow to it so my advice is don't stop
what you're doing uh we are here at this
moment because of the American Military
presence in that region because of what
the Israeli Defense Forces are doing uh
and frankly uh uh because of the the the
enormous pressure uh that the enormous
pressure that Israelis their society is
putting on Palestinians and Gaza and the
West Bank so I hope they don't let up
and I'm glad that these hostages there
just one thing I did want to say even
though it was my turn to ask questions I
just want to remind everybody that that
that is very likely that when these
hostages are released that they have
been given
instruction in order to protect the
family members who are left behind that
they've been given instruction to say I
was taken I was well taken care of
everything was fine they were really
kind to me everything was great just
remember that that they're under
incredible pressure and don't be fooled
by Hamas all right hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else